hey i've got a question for you why do
some guys
achieve great success in relationships
in work
and just in life itself
well there are many things many factors
that come into play
but one of the most important things
[Music]
habits some guys grow up they grow in
knowledge
and in wisdom and so they stop doing
things
that prevent them from being successful
in life
they stop doing things that prevent them
from improving
and moving forward in life they stop
doing things to prevent them from
achieving
success have you ever asked yourself
this question
what prevents you from being the best
version
of yourself what are the things that
hold you
back that you need to stop doing not at
your
20s 30s 40s but right now
in this video we're going to look at 10
things that all guys should stop doing
right now let's get to it
[Music]
i've made mistakes but mistakes make you
strong
the first thing you need to stop doing
is to let bad friends influence
you to be like them better yet
make sure you only have good friends
that makes
you a better person really growing up
and moving ahead in life
means also realizing that a lot of your
friends
aren't really your friends or
a lot of your friends aren't the french
that you should have
now a true friend can be closer to you
than the brother
a true friend will shape you and you
will shape them
as iron sharpens iron so a friend
sharpens
a frame wanting things for
free instead of working for it these
days
there seems to be a lot of guys who just
feel
entitled to everything for free
don't ever feel entitled to anything
that you haven't worked for nobody
it's not the government not your friends
not your family
nobody owes you anything for free
get up work for it with your own two
hands and take responsibility of your
own life
then when you achieve success yourself
you'll also appreciate it a lot more
you know i've heard this quote before
not sure where i've heard it before but
it goes like this
entitlement is a delusion built on
self-centeredness
and laziness it's so true
treating certain people like trash
unfortunately there's uh some guys out
there who feel that
they have to treat other people like
trash so that they can feel good about
themselves
but it's sad isn't it because it tells
us a lot about
you if you have to step on other people
just so you can feel better about
yourself and more confident
in who you are just to feel important
or better than someone else
the truth is this when you do it you
actually lower yourself
and show people you have low self-esteem
be careful of how you treat other people
because it will get back to you
because people will treat you the way
that you treat them
there is a story behind every person
there is a reason
why they are the way they are think
about that
and respect them for who they are mark
an angel
relying on your parents too much
look your parents are your parents
they're always going to be your parents
you need to respect them
and spend time with them because they
won't always be here
my father passed away a few years ago
and i miss him immensely but that's just
the point
your parents won't always be here so you
need to learn how to take care of
yourself they won't always be able to
look after you
you need to learn how to stand on your
own two feet
to take care of yourself and not when
you encounter
a problem just run to your parents or
family for help there's a lot of people
who do it even if it's just a little
problem they always
run to their family first to try and
help them know
stand on your own two feet
move into your own place be independent
and then grow into a man that can
support
his parents so when your parents grow
older
then you want to be the man that can
help them not vice versa
breaking your promises a real man
never ever breaks his promises
how do you feel when somebody makes a
promise to you
and then they just break it and then
pretend that it's nothing it doesn't
really matter
it's terrible isn't it so don't do it to
other people
man up be a man of your
word be a man that other people can look
up to
trust and respect
too much there are guys out there who
just make a habit of complaining about
everything and it just makes them
negative and everybody
around them negative and they don't even
realize that they're complaining about
everything all the time and drains you
physically emotionally when you're with
someone
that's just everything is just a problem
and an issue and he just complains
listen never waste your time by
complaining
why because it doesn't change anything
actually most of the time you just make
things worse complaining
doesn't solve problems it creates them
stop complaining stop wishing for
something else
and stop making excuses and start
working for the change you want
blaming other people for some guys it's
easier to blame
other people than to take responsibility
for their
own faults and it's also
yeah also lying to yourself if you blame
other people
tell yourself that it's not your problem
it's not your fault it's their fault or
that
guy or this girl then you're lying to
yourself if you don't take
responsibility for your own problems
and worse is if you believe your own
lies
listen you will fall many times in this
life
but that doesn't make you a failure if
you own it up
as a man you stand up and you you know
okay i did this wrong i did just wrong i
did just wrong
i need to repair it and do it different
that doesn't make you a failure
what makes you a failure is if you blame
other people
now that that makes you a failure
spending too much time on social media
look social media is not real life a lot
of people wear masks
pretending to be someone that they are
not and if you spend too much time on
social media it can influence you
without you even realizing it trying to
be like other fake people
be careful of what you put into your
brain
the kind of people that you follow you
gotta unfollow
bad role models those people who
influence you negatively
and spend less time on social media and
then if you do go on social media make
sure that you follow the right kind of
people
people who you can trust people who you
can respect look up to
good role models
stop swearing all the time some guys
feel without realizing it feel that they
need to use swear words all the time to
sound
cool they don't have enough confidence
in themselves
to just speak normally they believe that
it's not
enough they are not enough and people
are not going to like them if they just
speak normally
they need to kind of use all different
kind of swear words to make what they're
saying
interesting they think that their
charisma
is not enough and then the problem is
that all they're swearing
it actually causes the opposite it
actually puts people off
especially in professional situations
and then of course also another bad
habit
is that when people are a little bit
unsure of themselves or the situation
not sure what to
say they use swear words as a crutch
word david keough rightly said that
profanity
is the common crutch of the
conversational [ __ ]
swearing doesn't make you cool your
personality
your character that makes you cool
stop bragging you know these guys who
always just
have this need to just brag about
everything all the time
it's just oh look nobody cares how much
you can bench at the gym or how much you
can drink
or about your personal assets if you
have this need to brag
all the time about everything it shows
that there's something missing inside of
you
and that you don't have enough
self-confidence because
you need other people to think
that you are great in order to feel good
about yourself
if you are confident and if you know who
you are
you would not have a need to brag a liar
never have to tell you
it's a lion you see
insecurities always scream loud but
confidence
is silent you've heard that quote
somehow before right
it's true never ever brag about yourself
other people will do it if you inspire
them
just focus on working hard towards your
goals
and then your success will speak for you
stay humble stay kind stay grounded
and always remember this no matter how
big your arms are
how big your house is how big your bank
account is
our graves will be the same size and you
will take
nothing with you when you die so
live for people and not for things
i'll see you in the next video cheers
guys